Das Podcast Ufo.
Mit Florian Tiefel und Stefan Tiefel.
Das war unser Halloween-Inter, glaube ich.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge, einer schaurigen Folge des Podcast Ufo. Uuuuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuh hat und jetzt einfach noch so halb tot als Skelett rumliegt und man denkt so, komm, wir feiern jetzt einfach nochmal mit. Es ist schwierig, aber ich freue mich trotzdem auf diese Folge. Dein Name ist Stefan Tietze. Mein Name ist Stefan Tietze, dein Name ist Funtin Will. Das wird immer im Intro erwähnt und das wird auch noch mal erwähnt. Und wir erwähnen es alle 20 Minuten, damit, falls ihr auch erst in der Mitte dazustosst, falls ihr den Anfang verpasst habt und dann erst an der Tür klopft, kann ich mich noch setzen. Ja, könnt ihr jederzeit, ihr könnt jederzeit noch da rein. Schuhe ausziehen, um dann auf leisen Sohlen
hereinzuschleichen. Hast du ein schönes Horrorwochen
irgendwie gemacht am Halloween?
Ich habe mich gegruselt, ich habe mich gefürchtet,
ich habe gezittert, ich habe gebangt,
alles miterlebt.
Nee, gar nicht. Meine Cousine ist gerade in
Schottland, liebe Grüße nach Schottland.
Schottland. Hello
over there. Sie ist
da, also ich habe Halloween gar keinen
Bezug dazu, da ist es wohl ein bisschen grösser
Vielen Dank. Schottland. Hello, Schottland. Hello over there. Sie ist da, also ich habe Halloween gar keinen Bezug dazu, da ist es wohl ein bisschen grösser und es war fantastisch, weil sie da in so einem für Kinder arbeitet, in so einem grossen Schloss. Ich glaube, aber alles in Schottland ist ein Schloss, ich glaube, es ist nichts Besonderes, ich glaube, es ist einfach ein normales Haus, die sagen, es ist ein Haus, sagen die. Und das war ganz schön, weil da, das war mein einziger Blick in Richtung Halloween dieses Jahr, waren ihre Videos von den ganzen Leuten, die da geschmückt haben und so. Und dann ist es schon auch cool. Da haben die dann so den ganzen Wald geschmückt mit krassen Laternen und Skeletten. Dann denke ich mir, das hat dann was, und dann verstehe ich es auch, in Deutschland ist es halt so ein bisschen halbgar. Es ist halt so, es ist halt nicht wirklich da, und dann wird es jetzt eher so zum Anlass genommen zu trinken, sich noch mal zu kostümieren, noch mal Karnevalskostüm rauszuholen. Es ist aber jetzt auch keine, wenn es dann wenigstens eine Motto-Motto-Party-Gruselkostüme wäre. Vor allem ist es halt auch zu dieser schwierigen Jahreszeit, wo es oft schon so kalt ist, dass die Kinder halt ein Kostüm anhaben, aber darüber ein Anorak und eine Maske tragen.
Das heißt, selbst wenn ihr Gesicht geschminkt ist, man sieht es eh nicht.
Alle sehen gleich aus, Anorak mit Maske drüber und Mütze obendrauf.
Also alle sind gleich.
Aber ich verstehe auch nicht, warum man dadurch sagen kann, unsere kostümierten Festivitäten,
das ist ein bisschen schwierig auszudrücken jetzt, dass es catchy wird für unsere Petitionen, aber Petitionen, die kostümierten Festivitäten sind an den falschen Zeitpunkten im Jahr. Sowohl Karneval ist zu früh im Februar, als auch der 11.11. ist wieder viel zu spät, als auch der 31.10. ist viel zu spät. Wo sind die Kostüme im Sommer, frage ich mich. Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob man sowas willkürlich festlegen kann. Ich finde es ja ohnehin, muss man auch mal ganz kurz anmerken,
ich will jetzt nicht die Verschwörungstheorie-Ecke aufmachen,
aber ist es ein Zufall, dass
alle Feiertage so relativ
gleichmäßig aufs Jahr verteilt sind?
Weil die sind ja alle
in anderen Jahren stattgefunden.
Das heißt, es könnte auch sein,
also zum Beispiel Weihnachten ist ja ein ganz
anderes Jahr als Tag der Wiedervereinigung.
So, das ist ja 2000 Jahre auseinander.
Aber es könnte ja sein, dass es alles in derselben Woche wäre. Ich finde es mega, weil ich glaube, es hat sich natürlich so ergeben und dann blieb es so, weil es clever auseinanderliegt. Aber kennst du diese Kurve? Es gibt so eine mathematische Formel, das jetzt so als die Welterklärungsformel bezeichnet, völlig übertrieben. Meternachsformel Nazi-Formel, so eine wie Populationen, ich glaube, daher kamen die dann irgendwann, um Populationen zu berechnen, von irgendwelchen Insekten oder Spezies und so. Da wurde eine Formel berechnet und die, egal wo man anfängt, die gleicht sich dann irgendwann aus. Es pendelt sich halt irgendwie so zu einer Summe dann am Ende aus. Und so ist es auch ein bisschen bei den Feiertagen, glaube ich, weil eine Parallelwelt, wo alle Feiertage, weil man halt irgendwelche Tode gefeiert hat oder irgendwelche Geburten, und die sind alle im November, ich glaube, an irgendeinem Punkt hätte sich das auch eingependelt, dass am Ende, am Ende haben die auch einen Kalender, wo gleichmäßig Dinge verteilt werden. Weil ich glaube, wenn du das ganze Jahr nichts feierst und dann so Purge-mäßig im November die Sau rauslässt, ich glaube, dann ist es auch nicht so gut. Und das ist halt auch gut eingeklüngelt, da müssen wir auch nochmal Danke an Jesus sagen, dass der halt auch einfach nicht alles am selben Tag gesagt hat, dass er halt irgendwie geboren wurde und exakt 30 Jahre später am selben Tag Himmelfahrt, so an seinem Geburtstag, wo er dir schon gesagt hat, bist du dir wirklich sicher, dass du es am Geburtstag machen willst? Weil dir ist schon klar, dass feiertagstechnisch das halt ganz ungünstig ist und diese ganze brennende Strauchnummer. Kannst du bitte Ostern auferstehen? Das war, glaube ich, auch dann der Wunsch. Auch geklopft so. Wir hätten jetzt wieder Zeit für den Feiertag. Kannst du jetzt bitte auferstehen? Wir wären soweit, die Eier sind versteckt. Ja, ich habe mir schon freigenommen. Wir haben auch schon ein Hasenkonzept. In zwei Monaten ergibt das keinen Sinn mehr. Ich finde es ein bisschen befremdlich, dass du jetzt hier so Feiertage einstehst und sowas. Du bist jemand, der den Feiertage doch gar nicht interessieren dürften. Nee, Feiertage sind für mich eigentlich immer dasselbe. Ich stehe auf, will einkaufen gehen, stehe vom schwarzen Laden. Das ist eigentlich schlechter als sonst. Es ist eigentlich schlechter als sonst, es ist immer der schwarze Laden Tag. Schwarze Läden? Der Tag des schwarzen Ladens ist eigentlich jeder Feiertag, das ganze Jahr über. Ja, also es ist ein bisschen schlechter für dich als normale Tage. Richtig. Genau wie Sonntage ja auch ein bisschen schlechter für dich sind als normale Tage. Es ist ein bisschen schlechter, es dreht sich alles um, Ferien sind schlechter für mich, weil so viele Kinder unterwegs sind, die im Weg stehen. Weil so viele Kinder im Phantasialand im Weg stehen und den Weg zum Fleck Mamba versperren. Die verstopfen mich, die essen die ganze Zuckerwatte weg. Ja. Weg, also für mich die schlimmste Zeit des Jahres Sommerferien, Herbstferien, da, wenn es, ich glaube, je schlechter es Kindern geht, desto besser geht es mir gerade. Also es ist wirklich genau umgedreht. Und deswegen achte ich auch immer, ich gucke immer aus dem Fenster und schaue die Kinder an und wenn die gut draußen sage ich, nee, ich bleibe heute zu Hause, heute kann nur ein schlechter Tag werden. Ich hätte noch nie in meinem Leben einen Feiertag wahrgenommen. Also ich war noch nie Arbeitnehmer an einem Feiertag und ich konnte sagen, ah cool, ich kann heute ausschlafen oder sowas. Nie passiert. Weil man bei einer Fernsehsendung, die halt dann trotzdem stattfand mittwochs, und man konnte sich dann entweder entscheiden, machen wir eine schlechtere Sendung und arbeiten Montag nicht, weil es der Bus und B-Tag ist, oder arbeiten wir und die Sendung wird wie immer. Und dann hat man immer gesagt, komm, wir arbeiten lieber. Und dann war ich immer auch in der Firma. Wir haben ja letzte Woche angekündigt, dass ich, ich habe Hausaufgaben bekommen letzte Woche. Ich bin unglaublich aufgeregt gewesen von dieser Folge, weil ich habe vorhin die Hausaufgaben aufgegeben. Und wie du es vielleicht schon erwartet hast, ich habe leider, meine Hausaufgaben wurden leider, ich habe die leider im Bus mir nochmal angeguckt und dann habe ich die leider auf dem Sitzplatz vergessen. Also ich müsste heute nochmal mit der Busgemeinschaft mich kurz schliessen und dann kann ich ihnen die vielleicht in zwei, drei Wochen kann ich ihnen die geben, weil ich habe leider ... Ich verstehe das Konzept der Ausrede für Hausaufgaben nicht, weil du hast es ja nicht. Also warum ... Nein, ich habe es schon gemacht, ich habe es ja gemacht. Ich habe es dann nach ... Aber meine Strichliste mache ich ja ... Wir haben Hausaufgabenstriche bekommen, deswegen kriegst du jetzt einen Strich, weil du deine Hausaufgaben nicht gemacht hast. Du hast sie nicht mitgebracht. Ja, also ich war leider eine Zeit lang nicht da. Ich war in Berlin diese Woche oder am Wochenende und danach. Und deswegen hatte ich leider keine Zeit dafür. Nur zum Kiosk zu gehen. Ich hatte leider keine Zeit, zum Kiosk zu gehen. Es war schon abends, wenn ich mir dann noch eine Mate gekauft hätte, hätte ich nicht schlafen können. Es wäre schlecht gewesen für meinen Rhythmus und dann, ich hab's nicht, ich hab's nicht gemacht, ich hab's nicht gemacht. Sorry, Herr Lehrer, ich hab meinen Hausrat nicht gemacht, weil ich in Berlin war. Was ist das für eine Kackscheiße, aber gut. Ich hab's nicht, ich hab's nicht, das ist meine Ausrede. Ich hab's einfach nicht gemacht. Mir waren Schüler immer sympathisch, dass die einfach gesagt haben, ich habe es nicht.
Es gibt einen Running Gag noch bei uns in der Schulgruppe von einem, der dann meinte, ich sage einfach, ich habe die andere Aufgabe gemacht. Es war 6a und dann meinte er, ach 6a, ich habe 6b
gemacht und dann meinte der Lehrer, ja und lesen Sie doch mal die Lösung für 6b vor und er, okay, ich
habe es nicht. Es hat nicht viel gebraucht, um seinen Widerstand zu brechen. Es eine Nachfrage und er, ja, okay, sperren Sie mich ein. Aber der Lehrer auch gut gepokert, der Lehrer all in gesetzt auf, er liest halt das vor. Ach Gott, einfach so ganz schnell. Wo waren Sie denn zur Zeit des Mordes? Ich war im Fitnessstudio, aber die hatten gar nicht offen. Da lesen sie sechs Beispiele. Ja, okay, ich war's, sperrt mich ein, ich war's, okay. Einfach sofort aufgeben, sofort, ja okay, gut, dann war ich's halt. Shoot, sue me, okay, sperrt mich halt ein für Mord. Sperrt mich halt ein. Okay. Mein Gott. Ja, wir werden sie einsperren. Schuldig. Hier, ich war's. Hallo, tatütata, einmal einsperren bitte. The sassy murder. The sassy murder. Okay, sumi, ich hab ihn umgebracht. Okay, sumi. Oh ja, was steht in eurem Gesetzbuch drin, verboten oder uuuuh. Niemand bereut Ironie so sehr, wie der lebenslang dich kriegt. Einfach Scheiße. Ja gut, wie hast du heute Halloween verbracht? Du warst in Berlin, hast nicht im Kiosk gesessen, um den Instagram zu machen. Okay, gut, super enttäuschend, dass es keine Geschichte kommt, wie du mit dem Kioskbesitzer weiterkommst. Ja, es tut mir leid, es tut mir wirklich leid. Ich habe ihn tatsächlich noch mal gesehen, wie er Sachen rausholt, aber ich habe eine tolle Nachricht bekommen, warte, muss ich ganz kurz recherchieren, eine tolle Nachricht bekommen von jemandem, der einen Kollegen hat. Aber es gibt tatsächlich dieses Phänomen, dass Leute Sachen jedes Mal sagen, wenn sie irgendwas machen. Ja. Er scheint auf jeden Fall gängig zu sein. Ist ja auch so ein bisschen so ein Ehe-Ding auch, ne? Also fällt man halt häufig anerst auf, wenn man viel Zeit miteinander verbringt. Ich erinnere mich auch immer, dass mein Vater halt immer, nachdem er getrunken hat, immer ganz laut gemacht hat, was halt auch wahnsinnig nervig war. Ja, aber das haben wir auch schon darüber geredet. Oder immer nach dem Husten immer noch ein M-M-M. Das hat mich auch wahnsinnig gemacht. Das ist furchtbar. Also das sind so diese Eigenarten, die man halt immer macht. Und ich glaube, vielleicht ist das so ein Zwang von dem Kiosk-Besitzer. Absolut. Hier hat jemand geschrieben, dessen Namen ich nicht aussprechen kann. Das ist ein ganz kruder Nickname. Und er hat geschrieben... Das ist ein ganz kruder ausländischer Name. Ich hatte während meiner Ausbildung einen Herrn, der jeden Tag die Alufolie von seinem Kantinenessen abgezogen hat, mit den Worten, ah, was habe ich heute? Drei Jahre, ah, 365 Tage, hatte das insgesamt rund 900 Mal gesagt. Also auch keine Feiertage gehabt. Keine Feiertage, 900 Mal. Und man kann jede Woche bestellen und zwischen fünf Gerichten pro Tag wählen. Und er hat jedes Mal die Alufolie abgezogen und dann ist, ah, was habe ich heute. 900 Mal. Ist den Leuten bewusst, dass sie das sagen? Also ist das wirklich so ihr
Catchphrase, den sie sich zurechtgelegt
haben? Oder macht man das einfach
so nebenbei? Weil mir sagen ja auch oft Leute,
du sagst ständig das und das
und ich weiss es gar nicht.
Das ist etwas anderes.
Ja, ja, ja.
Mir reicht es gleich, hast du gehört?
Mir reicht es gleich. Ich raste gleich aus,
habe ich gesagt. Nee, aber gut, das ist auch gut. dein Gesicht passt nicht zu dem, was du gesagt hast. Bei dem ist es etwas anderes, finde ich, weil du ja professionell sprichst viel. Also da, klar, dass man irgendwie mal, du sagst das Wort tatsächlich häufig oder sowas, also nicht, dass es mir mal persönlich aufgefallen wäre, aber vielleicht schon das eine oder andere Mal, aber ist ja jetzt auch gar nicht schlimm. Also du kannst es vielleicht auch sein lassen. Also vielleicht kann man da in Zukunft ein bisschen darauf achten, aber in diesem Prinzip wäre erst mal nichts Schlimmes. Wohingegen sowas ist, glaube ich, das weiß ich jetzt nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Beim Kioskbesitzer bin ich mir nicht sicher, weil das auch sowas will dich zum Lachen bringen. Bei dem ist ja eher, es wirkt ja fast wie so ein Dad-Joke, das immer wieder zu machen. Ja, es stimmt schon, es ist die Frage. Aber auch hier wird mich natürlich interessieren, was ist, wenn man mal die Person darauf hinweist? Oder wenn die Person einmal es nicht sagt und der ganze Raum einfach schlagartig still wird, die ganze Kantine dreht sich um und niemand kann weitermachen. Bis Hitcom-Publikum, ja, round. Ah, was haben wir denn heute! International einsetzbare Reinrufe, wo man nicht genau hört, was ist, damit man das überall benutzen kann. Witz, eigentlich gerade, wird in den Corona-Zeiten eigentlich, werden Sitcoms ohne Publikumslacher ausgestrahlt, das finde ich wahnsinnig lustig, wenn Big Bang Theory genauso geschnitten, genauso gespielt, aber ohne Publikum. Oder so mit so ein bisschen gedämpften Lachern, weil alle Masken anhaben oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Hat irgendwie einen anderen Effekt, wenn alle so geknebelt wirken. Ja, und dann habe ich ihm gesagt, soll er sich selber mal angucken. Hilfe, Hilfe, nein, nein, so. Irgendwie fand ich die neue, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, heißt, alle Musiker, die da gespielt haben, müssen den Eindruck haben, sie haben mega enttäuscht, weil am Ende ist es nur so ein und da ist ja ein riesiges Was? Was? Orange? Mugabe. Was ist mit Robert Mugabe?
Aber es ist ja, wenn du so einen riesigen Saal hast, wirkt ja schon, wenn nur 20 Prozent
einfach ultra enttäuscht und du denkst dir dann so, moa, moa, mit Tuba, moa, moa. Du sprichst gerade von Künstlern, die nicht die Nachrichtenlage mitbekommen haben.
Es ist nicht so, dass die nicht davon wissen.
Die werden dann hier auf der Bühne sitzen und dann am Ende sagen, oh, merkwürdig, aber schlecht besucht heute. Das war was, schlecht besucht. Die Leute lieben doch normalerweise Brahms, was ist denn los? Und hast du mit dem alle Masken getragen? Ich bin mir sicher, dass es noch ein, zwei Fagottisten gibt, die noch nichts von Corona mitbekommen haben. Für die beiden war der Joke. Viel Spaß, Fred and George. Was für ein Zufall. Fred and George. Oder wie ein Fagott auch immer klingt. Ja, ich glaube ein bisschen höher. Ich weiß nicht, ich könnte viele Instrumente nachmachen aus dem Orchester, das Volkot gehört nicht dazu. Ich glaube, das ist auch der Holzklang, den man nicht nachmachen kann. Dieser herrliche feine Holzklang, wo man wirklich die Luft am Holz entlang sämen sehen kann. Herrlich, traumhaft. Holz riecht toll und klingt toll. Ich habe jetzt einen Schrank bekommen, feinerli, so einen Einbauschrank aus Holz und der riecht fantastisch. Ich erwische mich manchmal, wie ich dann nachts nochmal aufstehe, um einfach mal zu diesem Schrank zu gehen, einmal ganz doll eine Nase zu nehmen von diesem Schrank. Ja, es ist völlig selbstverständlich, dass du dich vor dem Fernseher sitzt und einfach eine Stunde lang schaust. Es ist aber ungewöhnlich, dass man eine Stunde lang aktiv riecht. Einfach so sagt so jetzt Warum, ja? Man riecht heute einfach mal. Man könnte ja auch so ein Buch machen, wo jede Seite anders riecht und man riecht dann einfach so einen Abend lang. Man riecht einfach bewusst, riecht dann einfach ein Buch. Auch ein bisschen dieses, was habe ich denn heute? Ein bisschen äquivalent ist dazu in Kochsendungen der Satz Ha, leider haben sie kein Geruchsfernsehen. Habe ich mich auch schon oft erwischt dabei, das zu sagen, ja. Ich mich auch.
Aber es ist immer so, es ist furchtbar, du kannst Gerüche schlecht beschreiben und du riechst es und du denkst, schade, dass ihr jetzt das nicht riechen könnt. Ja, genau. Und dann irgendwann war das nicht mehr der Satz. Dann war der Satz, schade, dass ich kein Geruchsfernsehen, das müsste mal jemand erfinden oder sowas. Ja.
Und das hört man auch ein bisschen zu häufig.
Aber das stimmt, warum kann man nicht, glaubst du, es gibt es mal irgendwann, dass man so geil riechen kann, dass es da irgendwie, aber guck mal, Essen, also viele Sinne sind schon eine Abendveranstaltung. Hören, Konzert, sehen, Netflix, fühlen, Massage, Waschanlagen, Auf Waschmaschinen setzen. Auf Waschmaschinen setzen. Waschanlagen. Waschanlagen. Aber hingegen riechen, schmecken, essen, tolles Essen. Ja, schmecken. Ist auf jeden Fall eine Abendveranstaltung. Was ist mit Balance, ist doch auch ein Sinn, oder? Skateboarden? Ja, jetzt hast du diesen neunten Sinn, der von den Bleichen der Pluto aberkannt hat. Okay, dann machen wir einen Kompromiss. Pluto raus, dafür kommt Balance als Sinn dazu. Balance. Sie sind der Einzige, der klatscht und der Einzige, der auf den Tisch haut. Hallo. Mit beiden Köpfen, mit Kopf und Elbe. Kopf und Elbe, Wo wir noch nehmen, damit es noch mehr klingt.
Aber alle sehen, dass er das alleine macht.
Ja, aber stell dir einen Oktopus vor, der einfach für vier Leute klatscht.
Sehr gut.
Nur du klatscht.
Wir haben alle Bojack Horseman gemacht.
Aber in Bojack Horseman ist es eine Spinne, okay?
Jokes are new, jokes are new.
Steal like an artist.
Steal like an lazy artist.
Aber ich glaube tatsächlich, dass Balance irgendwann hinzugefügt wurde.
Ja.
Ich meine, ich bin auch kein Fan von Balance.
Welcher, was für ein Arschloch-Wissenschaftler, der irgendwann gesagt hat, dieses Unami ist ein Geschmack, Balance ist ein Sinn und Pluto ist kein Planet.
Genau. So, kommt ihr alle noch mal zusammen, bitte.
Eine Sache noch.
Der Daumen.
Kein Finger.
Ach komm, Scholl.
Das ist doch nicht
dein Ernst. Was ist
es denn sonst?
Greifobjekt
Zwergfinger.
Däumling.
Moment, Moment, Moment, was steht derfinger. Däum, Däumling. Zwergfinger.
Moment, Moment, Moment, was steht der denn schon auf?
Setzt euch hin.
Leute.
Ja, was, was, was noch?
Weiss.
Oh mein Gott, das wissen wir.
Keine Farbe.
Ist wieder eine Farbe.
Weiss ist jetzt doch wieder eine Farbe.
Ja.
Und der Arm geht langsam hoch von einem Journalisten. Schwarz, ist da schwarze Farbe? Schwarz ist ein Finger. Schwarz! Finger? Schwarz ist ein Finger! Schreib's auf! Schreib's auf! Schwarz ist ein Finger! Ich hab ein Litergerät, ich muss nichts aufschreiben. Wirklich? Ja. Wir sind moderne Journalisten. In welchem Jahr glauben Sie, findet diese Veranstaltung statt? Ach so, ich war jetzt irgendwie in so einem Wild-West-Setting gerade. Ach so, okay. Sorry, Charlie. Ich habe mir die Szene gerade falsch vorgestellt. Passt zu Ihnen auf eine Art, dass Sie in diesem Setting sind? Das wäre, glaube ich, so. Du hast ja gesagt, du suchst nach deiner Persönlichkeit, deinem Charakter, weil das alles erbärmlicher Schrott ist, den du hervorgebracht hast. Aber so Sporen, glaube ich, wäre eine Ansage. Sporen, also so diese Sterne an den Schuhen, die immer so klappern, wenn man läuft, wie so ein Cowboy. Das wäre mal eine Ansage. Ich trage jetzt Sporen. Joyhose, aber Sporen. Why making the effort there? Aber auch keine Cowboy-Schuhe, sondern einfach schöne Sneaks, schöne einfach ein paar Jaw-Breezeys, aber einfach schön mit Sporen dran. Also Air-Breezeys und dann Sporen dran. Air-Breezeys und Sporen. Vielleicht bringt auch Nike das demnächst raus, die neuen Sneaks mit Sporen. Haben wir nicht gesagt Flugmodus, Stefan? Ja, du hast heute tatsächlich gesagt Flugmodus. Ich wollte, habe mich auch heute noch mal drauf bestanden, weil du sonst immer nebenbei noch mal scrollst und schön die Aktien im Blick hast. Nee. Und schön dann immer so dir die Nase reibst, wenn du wieder Geld verdienst. Ich kenne dich doch mittlerweile. Was mache ich? Das verrät mich. Ja, immer wenn du Geld verdienst, reibst du dir die Nase. Und wenn ich Geld verliere? Dann ist Kinn. Und so kannst du in deinem Gesicht, und wenn es so Medium bleibt, dann den Mund. Anzeigen lassen, wo dein Kontostand gerade ist. Ich bin ein offenes Buch. Du bist ein wirklich sehr offenes Buch. Man kann den Kontostand auf den 10 Euro genau lesen, wo du gerade bist. Okay, jetzt sind wir bei so 2000, 2000 Kontostand. 2000, wer will die mehr? Ja, sorry, ich habe das nicht im Flugmodus gemacht. Beziehungsweise mein Handy schon, aber mein, ne, das stimmt ja gar nicht. Brauche ich dir gar nicht anlügen. Wenn du weißt, dass mein Laptop pinkt, muss mein Handy auch anlögen. Ist doch gut, Stefan, ist doch okay, ist doch locker. Bist du ein Flugmodus-Guy? Ich habe schon ein paar Mal beobachtet, dass Leute im Flugger nicht anmachen, habe ich schon ein paar Mal beobachtet. Nee, bei mir ist es genau andersrum. Für mich ist Flugmodus fast der normale Modus. Und ich bräuchte eigentlich eher einen Modus dafür, wenn ich im Flugzeug bin. Also ich bräuchte dann den Mondmodus, den Flügelmodus für Flugzeuge, weil ich den Flugmodus so oft benutze, obwohl ich nicht im Flugzeug bin. Verstehst du, was ich meine? Ja, ja. Ich mag das einfach. Du bist wie umgekrempelt. Kennst du das, wenn du duscht und dann nimmst du deine Arme so vor den Bauch und sammelst so Wasser an in deinen Armen und lässt es dann so auf einen Schlag runterplatschen? Genauso mache ich es mit meinem Handy auch. Flugmodus ist es Arme vom Bauch. Ist es bei dir, es gab oft die Diskussionen, was nicht für mein Leben spricht, aber sammelst du, willst du massiv viel Wasser sammeln oder willst du, und das ist bei mir so, den grösstmöglichen Knall erzeugen, wenn das Wasser auf den Boden lag. Ich will aus, aus, ich will den größtmöglichen Knall, ich will den Schwall, ich will den Platsch. Ich liebe für den Platsch. Du liebst den Platsch. Ja. Ja, ich auch. Und so ist Flugbonus für mich auch ein bisschen, Flugmodus an, eine Stunde warten und dann so, ja, jetzt gib mir die Nachrichten, gib mir die Likes. Bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, einfach Mahnung, Mahnung, abgelehnt, Wikipedia-Beitrag wurde verändert, so lauter solche Nachrichten. Ja, bei dem, was ist das für eine App? Was war das jetzt? Slack kenne ich ja noch. Ja, Entschuldigung, was sind Sie für eine App? Ja, Sie ja mit dem Ton gerade. Nee, mit mir kann man laufen, ich bin eine Lauf-App. Moment mal! App hat sich selbst gelöscht. Car2Go ist weggefahren. Was man sich für eine App, nee, mit mir kann man nichts. Kann man Postboten verfolgen. Aber deswegen habe ich immer gerne Flugmodus an, weil ich dann selber kontrollieren kann, man die Leute auf mich zukommen und dann anrufe, hat sie angerufen und so und dann, ja dann rufe ich auch nicht zurück und so, aber das an sich mache ich schon ganz gerne. Ja, ein bisschen um einem das Gefühl zu geben, man wäre beliebter als man ist, weil man sonst keine hat, aber man kann ja auch keine bekommen, weil ich habe ja das Flugbonus an, wie soll ich noch Nachrichten bekommen und dann irgendwann machst du das wieder an, öffnest die, wie heißt das, Schotten. Die Schotten, genau. Aber man macht die Schotten nur dicht, man macht sie nicht auf, oder? Das ist ein seltener Befehl. Mach die Schotten auf! Sir, das haben wir nie geprobt. Der Herr macht die da einfach auf, die müssen aufgehen. Sir, wir können die Schotten dicht machen, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie ich sie aufmache. Alle Schotten auf! Terry, wie machen wir sie auf? Du schüttelst mit dem Kopf. Du schüttelst wie jemand mit dem Kopf. Du hast nicht meinen Dudelsack. Das ist toll, höre ich manchmal tatsächlich gerne. Ich auch. Dudelsack ist so ein bisschen Guilty Pleasure von mir. Ich höre Musik. Hast du mal geübt? Ein Gummelt von mir hat sich mein Dudelsack gekauft, ultra nervig. Aber noch lieber als Scotland Brave höre ich Loch Lomond. Das ist nämlich auch die Melodie vom FC Kölle. Irrefeld, Radladal, Nippes, weiss nicht, ein Schlagteil fällt mir immer nicht ein, Esch, Pesch und Kau. Überall jedes Fans um FC Köln. Das ist auch ein alter schottischer Song. Und irgendwie glaube ich auch, weil manche Karnevalsongs, so urkölsche Songs, die noch ein bisschen auf die kölsche Musikkultur eingehen, sind sehr ähnlich den keltischen schottischen Songs. Ich glaube, da besteht irgendwie eine enge musikalische Verbindung. Die konnte ich noch nicht verifizieren. Wenn man nämlich kölsche Songs und schottische Songs eingibt, findet man keine Gemeinsamkeiten unbedingt. Also wenn ihr mal wieder nach einem lächerlichen Bachelorarbeit Thema suchen müsst oder sowas, dann kann das ja jemand untersuchen. Vielleicht gibt es da irgendeine Verbindung, irgendeinen Maulwurf, der da irgendwie so durch so einen Tunnel gegraben hat oder so und der da die Noten übergeben hat. Oder irgendwie so zwei Leute, die sich getroffen haben und die Musikkultur ausgetauscht haben. Da besteht auf jeden Fall eine Korrelation. Auf jeden Fall ist der, wobei vielleicht auch nicht, die Kölner haben einfach geklaut. Das kann auch sein. Gut, kann auch sein. Oft ist das einfach Kultur, oft auch Steel like a musician. Steel like a fucking musician. Mensch, was habe ich heute gelacht? Du hast heute gelacht? Was habe ich heute gelacht? Ich habe heute mal in der Öffentlichkeit richtig gelacht. Oh mein Gott. Ich fand es nur mittellustig, aber ich habe richtig laut gelacht. Schöne Supermarktsituation, und du kennst es ja oft, du kaufst was ein, Supermarkt, dann zahlst du und dann wird dir der Bon hingestreckt. Der Diquiton. Der Diquiton. Der Diquit wird dir hingestreckt und du, nein danke, ganz gönnerhaft, nein danke, lehnst ihn ab. Nein danke, stecken Sie es ein. Stecken Sie es ein. Behalten Sie es selber. Kaufen Sie sich was Schönes. Kaufen Sie sich was Schönes. Und heute kam es zu einem kleinen Ulk, könnte man sagen, und zwar ein Herr, der Herr von mir an der Kasse hatte schon bezahlt, eingekauft und hat noch als Rückgeld einen 10-Euro-Schein bekommen. Kassierer hält ihm den 10-Euro-Schein hin und er sagt reflexartig, nee, danke. Und was haben die beiden gelacht? Ha! Da hätten sie fast den 10-Euro-Schein nicht genommen und die beiden lachen und es war wirklich so ein sekundenlanges Lachen und ich dachte mir, ich muss jetzt einsteigen und hab die Arme hochgeworfen und die Arme hochgerissen und hab laut die Arme hochgerissen, du hast die Situation beobachtet. Das ist genau wie bei der Achterbahn, wenn man kurz bevor man wieder ins Häuschen einfährt, dann noch die Arme hochreilt. Und alle so, nein. Und so war es auch, die beiden haben schallend gelacht, sich wirklich angelacht, also wirklich so ein Augen aufreißen, Augenkontakt, Mund aufgerissen, ahaha, also wirklich so wie eine Comicfigur lacht, sich richtig laut angelacht und es war so ein Abflossen. Bäuche haben gewackelt, also wirklich laut Tränenflossen. Leute haben sich erschreckt an der Nachbarkasse, sind zusammengezuckt, kurz, was ist da nebenan so ein Geräusch. Aber jetzt mal ganz ehrlich, wie war dein Lachen? War dein Lachen auch reflexartig, wie man das mag und liebt, impulsiv, du musstest wirklich auch lachen darüber? Oder hattest du gedacht, das ist gerade so, daneben zu stehen und ernst zu gucken? Es war ein soziales Lachen, weil ich habe das Ganze verfolgt mit den Augen, also meine Augen hingen dran, also so wie beim Tennis, wo man immer so hier und her guckt, habe ich diesen 10-Euro-Schein verfolgt. Ich war mir der Situation gewahr. Der humoristische Aspekt ist mir nicht entgangen. Sagen wir es mal so. Ich habe dann auch realisiert, aha, hier bahnt sich gerade eine Komik an, die nicht zu leugnen ist. Und dann, ah, jetzt wird hier, aha, jetzt wird hier das Zwerchfell vibriert hier in diesen beiden Körpern gerade. Und da dachte ich mir, ja, das ist schon lustig. Also das kann man schon machen. Kann man schon machen. Und dann abgesegnet, abgestempelt, ja, für lustig befunden, geht einmal durch alle Instanzen. Antrag hing kurz ein bisschen fest, ehrlich gesagt, irgendwo, weiß man nicht, ist untergegangen. Antrag schnell abgewickelt, zack, Brief kam an und dann habe ich auch schallend mitgelacht. Habe ich mir dann auch gegönnt, habe ich angeschlossen. Aber die Augen haben nicht mitgelacht wahrscheinlich. Die Augen haben nicht mitgelacht, die Augen waren steif, einfach auf einen Punkt in der Distanz gerichtet. Und trotzdem habe ich aber gelacht, Hände haben gefuchtelt, herumgefuchtelt, haben versucht Halt zu finden. Körper, Knie wurden weich, ich hatte keine Standkraft mehr, konnte mich aber noch festhalten. Ich liebe Oberkörperlacher, die so nach vorne werfen, dass die Beine hinterher müssen, finde ich fantastisch immer. Ich bin leider ein Klatscher manchmal, wenn ich was sehr lustig finde. Mag ich nicht so gern. Nee, finde ich gut. Nee, mag ich nicht. In dem Moment würde ich, also wenn ihr mich klatschen seht nach einem Lachen, ist danach das Lachen gespielt. Weil ich bin selber so, ich bin so runtergerissen von dieser Geste von mir, dass ich das nicht mag. Und danach ist dann nur noch ein soziales Lachen. Das ist immer so verrückt, wenn man Sachen sieht, von denen man davor nur gehört hat und dachte, das ist so aus Filmen oder so., wie zum Beispiel, wenn sich jemand wirklich auf den Schenkel klopft. Und das machen Leute, so das passiert wirklich und es ist einfach so, was geschieht da, was war zuerst da, der Ausdruck, Schenkelklopfer oder dass Leute das tatsächlich gemacht haben? Das weiß man nicht. Aber Unterschenkel, oder? Wir reden, wenn es heißt Schenkelklopfer, reden wir Unterschenkel. Man schlä erstmal ein bisschen verbiegen und verbögen. Man muss sich erstmal im Schneidersitz auf den Boden setzen, um dann wie ein Bongo-Solo auf seinen Unterschenkeln zu trommeln. Genau. Mir ist eine ähnliche Situation passiert. Ja, du hast schallend gelacht? Nee, ich habe nicht schallend gelacht. Als ich in der Schweiz war, kam eine Kassierin zu mir. Und ich hatte, ehrlich gesagt, den ganzen Schweizaufenthalt dieser Arroganz zu behaupten, das ist mehr so ein Dialekt, das ist keine andere Sprache. Und musste dann immer mehr lernen, ich verstehe kein Wort, das ist eine eigene Sprache, aber das hat er retrospektiv eingesetzt, dieses Bewusstsein. Für mich war es da immer noch einfach pure Arroganz.
Oft auch in den Niederlanden so, dass man sich einfach denkt, naja, da kommt man rein. Ja, ehrlich gesagt ja. Aber nein, tut man nicht. Auf keinen Fall, das ist eine andere Spare, machen wir uns nichts vor, das ist nicht zu verstehen. Und dann wurde ich abkassiert und dann war ich im Café und ich habe die Summe nicht verstanden. Ich dachte, ich hätte gehört, 17 Euro oder Franken, 17 Franken. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, 20 stimmt. So. Und dann habe ich in den Augen gesehen, irgendwas an dieser Konversation hat nicht funktioniert. Und auch mein Gegenüber hat gesagt, hat die Augen aufgerissen.
Was ist, und ich dachte mir, in welches Fettnäpfchen bin ich jetzt getreten? Ich wusste, ich war in der Zutreten, ich roch's schon, aber ich hab's nicht gewusst. Und dann dämmerte mir, hab ich gefragt, wie viel hat das gekostet? Und dann hat es tatsächlich nur elf Franken gekostet oder so was, oder zwölf. Und ich habe viel zu viele Trinker gegeben. Und dann, ja, kein steilendes Gelächter, das war einfach nur eine Sprache. Aber hast du zurückgerudert? Und dann habe ich zurückgerudert. Und dann wurde es sehr unangenehm, weil dann hat man schon mal jemandem mit zwanzig versprochen. Ja. Also, und auch wenn es der Person klar war, das ist jetzt gerade ein Missverständnis gewesen, glaube ich, so unterbewusst hat diese Person schon mit diesen 20 Euro gearbeitet. Die hat die schon verbucht. Und dann muss sie zurückgucken und sagen, da hole ich mir heute mal das Markenmus-Schokolade. Und dann gilt auch meine, ehrlich gesagt, meine 10-Prozent-Regel gilt immer, und dann aufrunden. Je nachdem. Also bei 18 oder 17 hätte ich gesagt, 1,70 Euro, 1,80 Euro Trinkgeld. Und dann ist man fast bei 20 und alles andere wäre lächerlich. Also gibt man 20. Jetzt bei so 12 wäre ich dann bei 1,20 Euro, wäre ich bei 13, 14. Also da ist schon ein Unterschied, weil du dann nicht mehr zu 20 aufrunden würdest. Und zu 15 ist es keine so gerade Zahl, die ich aufrunden würde, als ob ich im Endeffekt so 13 gegeben. Und da war die Diskrepanz da plötzlich so gross, obwohl die Summen gar nicht so weit auseinander waren, dass man sich schon ein bisschen geschämt hat und schon sehr weit zurückgerudert ist. Aber da sind wir wieder bei unserem Unterschied, dass du ein knallharter Typ bist und ich nicht. Ich hätte wahrscheinlich es bei 20 belassen. Einfach zwanzig, dann hätte ich mich, glaube ich, auch gut gefühlt im Moment, weil es macht ja auch manchmal Spaß, einfach zu viel zu zahlen und einfach, das ist ja so, also ich habe das Gefühl, in Filmen zahlen die Kuhlen immer viel zu viel. Also es ist oft so, keine Ahnung, dann auch irgendwie so, der Ritter ist auf seinem Pferd und dann sagt er, ja, wir müssen jetzt hier, hier baut er mal einen Stall und dann gibt er so dieses, dieses Bündelmünzen einfach. Ja, das Bündelmünzen, die immer passen. Das ist nicht nachgezählt, das ist irgendwie einfach, oder irgendwie auch bei Ritter aus Leidenschaft, wo er diese Goldstatue gewinnt und dann sagt er so, ja, irgendwie reparier meine Rüstung und dann schlägt er so den Kopf ab von dieser Statue und dann hat er diesen Goldkopf und das ist einfach so, ja, da wird niemand sagen, oh, das reicht aber nicht so, sondern das ist auch mit so einem Selbstbewusstsein gegeben, dass man einfach sagt, aber ich weiß auch nicht, ob das damals wirklich so war, dass man es eher so geschätzt wurde oder man einfach sagt so, hier hast du deinen Sack Mehl und dann sagt man, das ist aber eigentlich 1,4 Säcke Mehl, nee, du hast das, gibst das einfach so. Mir gefällt das auch nicht mehr, dass man mittlerweile so genau sein muss. Nee, du haust einfach so eine, wirklich so dieses Säckel.
Das finde ich ohnehin ganz geil.
Vor allem, hatten Ritter dann mehrere von diesen Säckeln?
Oder war das der ganze Geldbeutel?
Oder ist das ihr gesamtes Vermögen?
Oder ist die Übersetzung verloren gegangen, dass da drauf ganz klar die Summe stand? Das kann auch sein, dass es so vorher abgewogen ist, wie so eine bunte Tüte, die dann einen Euro kostet, wo du weißt, da wurde penibel jede einzelne saure Pommes reingetan. Da ist wirklich aufs Gramm genau abgewogen, genau so viel Wert. Da stand so eine große 15 drauf, aber die ist dann im Museum irgendwann so ausgeblichen. Das kann sein, ja. Und dann dachten wir so, hä, wir haben die bezahlt, an er einfach hingeworfen. Nein. Oder hat man... Wie Dinosaurier, die ja auch bunte, farbige Gefiederkleider mit Dreadlocks hatten. Bunte Dreadlocks hatten. Die sind ja auch in der Besetzung verloren gegangen. Kann aber auch sein, dass der einen größeren Sack hat, mit kleineren Säckeln drin, um dann einfach bei jeder Zahlung einen so einen Säckel zu werfen. Ja, aber guck mal, das wird ja auch eine Szene für unseren Comedy-Ritterfilm, dass er einen Säckel wirft und dann sagt, ja, den Sack will ich auch wieder zurück. Ich finde gut, wenn wir einfach Monty Python alles nachmachen ab jetzt. Wir machen einen Comedy-Ritter-Film, wir machen einen Comedy-Jesus-Film. Ja, ja. Werbung. Erst mal Spaß bei der Seite kurz, okay? Spaß weg. Ja, Spaß bei der Seite. Weisst du, ob du versichert bist?
Das ist ein wundes Thema, weil ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung, welche Versicherung ich habe, welche ich noch brauche.
Und ich glaube, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ich irgendwann mal richtig in Schwierigkeiten komme, weil ich nicht die richtige Versicherung habe, ist extrem hoch.
Wenn ich jetzt wirklich ernst. Ja, das meine ich auch ernst. Ich weiß auch viel zu wenig darüber.
Jetzt beim Umzug habe ich ein bisschen aufgeräumt in meinem Leben, weil man es ja auch macht, muss physisch. Deswegen weiß ich jetzt ungefähr, wo ich versichert bin, aber es geht doch viel einfacher, nämlich mit der neuen App Clark. Und die gibt es erst seit 2015, hat aber mittlerweile schon 200.000 Kunden, weil du hast einfach deine ganzen Versicherungen in einen Blick. Und die App verrät dir sogar Tipps, wo du dich vielleicht noch ein bisschen besser versichern solltest, etc.
Insider-Tipps.
Insider-Tipps. Das ist alles kostenlos. Du musst nur in den App-Store gehen oder in den Google Play Store, heisst es so, und musst dann da Clark suchen. C-L-A-R-K. Weil das nicht gut genug ist, legen wir da was oben drauf. Mit dem Gutscheincode UFO15 bekommt ihr einen 15-Euro-Amazon-Gutschein, wenn ihr eine existierende Versicherung hochladet, und wenn ihr zwei existierende Versicherungen auf Clark hochladet, bekommt ihr sogar einen 30-Euro-Amazon-Gutschein, alles mit dem Gutscheincode Ufo15. Werbung. Es sind einfach die besten Themen, aber ich glaube, das letzte Mal, als ich zu viel gezahlt habe, war an einem verzweifelten Sonntag.
Du hast es vorhin schon angesprochen, Sonntag, der schlimmste Tag der Woche.
Die Eltern haben nicht offen.
Ich würde lieber sonntags arbeiten, wirklich.
Ja, ich wollte mir was Schönes kochen. Ich dachte mir, heute ist ein Sonntag, heute geniesst du mal so ein bisschen dein Leben, irgendwie richtig so kulinarisch, lässt es heute mal richtig krachen.
Und dann habe ich was Feines angerührt und ich habe hauptsächlich zwei Gerichte, die ich koche und ich habe mich für das Erste entschieden, was Spinatnudeln sind. Und besteht aus drei Zutaten, relativ simpel, Spinat, Nudeln, Wasser und ein schönes Zitrönchen. Zitrönchen muss natürlich immer noch dazu. Du bist ein Zitronen-Fan, ne? Ich bin ein Zitronen-Fan, ich mag es immer ganz gerne, wenn da noch so eine kleine Säurenote drin ist. Ich hatte aber keine Zitrone. So, jetzt dachte ich mir aber, nein, ich bin ja clever. Ich weiß, dass es am Kölner Hauptbahnhof diesen einen Rewe to go gibt. Die haben auch so eine Obstabteilung. Die haben die Obstabteilung. Gehst du da schön hin, ja, gehst du da hin, bin ich hingegangen. Schuhe an, Hose an, Jacke angezogen, Tür auf, hinter mir, Tür abgeschlossen, Treppe runter. Du musst nicht alle Details sagen. Okay, ich mach's kurz. Ich war am Hauptbahnhof im Rewe to go, stellt sich raus, keine Zitrusfrüchte. Keine Zitrusfrüchte. Ich war mir hundert Prozent sicher, dass sie Zitrone haben, hatten sie nicht. Aber du hast ja erstmal alle anderen Zitrusfrüchte gecheckt, um diesen Satz sagen zu können.
Keine Zitrusfrüchte.
Ist ein bisschen so sensationalistisch.
Sag mal das, du bist für die Sensation.
Du machst eine Headline.
Ich mache eine Headline draus.
Also dir reicht nicht zu sagen, der hat keine Zitronen, du willst sagen, der hat keine Zitrusfrüchte.
Also du kannst mal alle anderen Zitrusfrüchte gecheckt.
Keine Zitrusfrüchte beim Revy2Go-Skandal.
Es klingt einfach, es klingt besser. Und ich habe dann auch geguckt, dann habe ich überlegt, wie experimentell kann man sein? Könnte man zum Beispiel auch aus einer Limo die Kohlensäure rausschütteln? Ein anderes Gericht zusammenzustellen, ist dir gar nicht in den Sinn gekommen. Nein, zu keinem Zeitpunkt ging mir das im Kopf rum. Ich habe eher überlegt, könnte ich irgendwie, keine Ahnung, es gab so Zitronenkekse, kann ich
die in den Spinat tun, kann ich
eine Limo irgendwie die Kohlensäure
rausschütteln und reintun.
Zitrone vielleicht einfach. Die Zitronenfritt,
kann ich die reinrühren.
Sowas in der Ecke, geht das?
Ja, clever, clever, clever.
Dann war ich aber am Ende meines Latein
und
dann dachte ich mir, was mache ich jetzt? Schaue ich mal bei den anderen Läden am Hauptbahnhof, ob die irgendwo Zitronen haben. Da verkauft zwar niemand Zitronen, aber vielleicht haben die ja Zitronen. Also dass zum Beispiel so ein Pizza hat, hat Zitronen rumliegen, falls jemand den einen Zitronen-Slushy bestellt, damit die dann eine Scheibe da dran tun kann. Die berühmte Pizza... Pizza Limone! Limoncelle! Und damit die da eine frische Zitronenscheibe als Deko. Mein Gott, Stefan, mach es doch nicht so schwer. Es ist eine Deko-Zitrone, dass du da einfach ein bisschen was fürs Auge dabei hast. Aber du gehst all in für so Gerichte. Das finde ich ja toll. Ja, vor allem, ich hatte mir... wie gesagt, hast du mich ja leider unterbrochen, aber ich hatte ja schon die Schuhe angezogen und ich hatte ja mir meine Kopfhörer aufgesetzt und dann dachte ich mir, das will ich jetzt nicht alles umsonst gemacht haben. Die Treppe haben wir komplett übersprungen, aber ich bin ja die Treppe auch noch runtergelaufen. Ja, aber dann hättest du vielleicht jetzt nicht diese Verschnittenschwierigkeiten. Ich war ja die Treppe extra runtergelaufen und dann dachte ich mir, ich brauche eine Zitrone und bin rumgelaufen, wo kriege ich diese Zitrone her?
Zitrone sind dann zum D geworden. Man ist schon dann beim D angekommen. Wenn man ist vom T weg, ist es eine Zitrone.
Es ist eine Zitrone. Und dann habe ich tatsächlich bei so einem Kaffeeladen gefragt, weil ich dachte, vielleicht haben die irgendwie auch Tees.
Tee mit Zitrone, Dekoscheibe oder sowas. Und dann habe ich gefragt, Entschuldigung, das klingt jetzt ein bisschen merkwürdig. Sorry. Das würdest du jetzt wahrscheinlich vom Hocker hauen. Aus den Socken schlagen. Aus den Socken und vom Hocker hauen. Vom Hocker in die Socken rein. aus den Schuhen katapultieren, dann Socken weg und dann ohne Socken zurück in die Schuhe. Nur damit sie vorgewarnt sind. Haben sie eine Zitrone? Socken, Hocker, Hocker, Socken, Schuhe. Ich verstehe, dass Sie keine Zitrone auf der Speisekarte haben, junge Dame, aber haben Sie eine Zitrone? Und die guckt mich an, als hätte sie einen Alien gesehen. Aber man kennt das, diese Gespräche, die man führt, wo man dann immer schon das Gespräch, die Antwort vorwegnimmt. Einem ist etwas so unangenehm zu fragen, dass man schon in seine Fragestellung einbaut, ich weiß, das ist normalerweise nicht üblich. Also man nimmt ihm schon die erste, diese erste Hintertür, die die haben im Gespräch, nimmt man den schon weg, nimmt man die ein bisschen in seine eigene Emission. Aber die Leute haben immer Bock auf das, was kommt. Immer wenn du zu jemandem gehst und sagst, das klingt jetzt ein bisschen komisch, hast du die eigentlich schon gewonnen. Die Leute sagen, ich bin dabei. Ich bin egal, was jetzt kommt, ich bin dabei. Ich kann nichts hier machen, weil das wäre ich rausgeworfen, aber I'm totally in. Ganz kurz, du sagst mir sofort, was du dir das ganz inzwischen ist. Also, ich hatte die Schuhe an, Hose an, Mütze auf, so und dann habe ich die gefragt, klingt ein bisschen komisch, haben sie die Zitrone und dann guckt die mich an, also als hätte sie wirklich, also du kannst nicht glauben, du kannst nicht glauben.
Jetzt ist es das zweite Mal, dass du die Geschichte unterbrichst.
Ja, sorry, verliegt es einfach daran, dass du Geschichten mittlerweile anders erzählst als andere.
Und sie schaut sich um und macht ein paar Schubladen auf und hatte tatsächlich in der Schublade eine Zitrone.
Hä? In der Zitronenschublade?
In der Zitronenschublade war eine Zitrone drin. Nein, ganz kurz. Zitrusfrüchte gehören nicht in die Schublade. Das habe ich mir auch gedacht. Da war ich jetzt erstmal und dann meinte sie auch, das würde dich jetzt verwundern, aber ich habe in der Schublade eine Zitrusfrucht gefunden. Und dann kannst du sagen, das wird das, was jetzt passiert, wird sie auch wundern, aber ich kann nur mit einem Geldsäckel bezahlen.
Und dann sagt sie, das wird dich jetzt auch wundern, aber du kannst es mir hinlegen, am Klang erkenne ich, wie viel Geld das ist. Dann hat sie mir die Zitrone gegeben und dann war erst mal so die Frage, Gegenleistung, kann ich was für dich tun? Und dann habe ich ihr schön einen Fünf-Euro-Sche gegeben. Und die haben mich angeguckt, als hätte ich ihr ein Porsche geschenkt. Er war wirklich so, das kann ich nicht annehmen. Und er hat gesagt, ja, komm, steckst du ein, steckst du ein Mädchen. Ha, kauf dir was Schönes. 5 Euro. Oh mein Gott. Und erst am nächsten Tag ist mir klar geworden, dass das eine Menge Geld ist. Und dann ich gesagt, kann ich vielleicht 4,50 Euro wieder zurückkommen. Am nächsten Tag kurz zurückkommen, das klingt jetzt vielleicht komisch, aber gestern, bei einer anderen Kollegin, weil in diesen Geschichten ist sie dann immer nicht mehr da, du kommst am nächsten Tag an, ist der Besitzer des Ladens da und du sagst, das klingt jetzt vielleicht ganz merkwürdig. Sehr gut, ja, stimmt schon. Wahrscheinlich schon und dann musst du dahin gehen und das das die Geschichte erklären und sagen. Ja, Spinat ist angebrannt, ich habe ihn weggeschmissen und habe mir schön Mr. Tom geholt am Kiosk. Aber es ist egal, es geht um die Zitrone. Im Endeffekt geht es um die Zitrone. Am Endeffekt geht es um die Zitrone, aber ich finde das Konzept in einer Zitronenschublade mindblowing. Ja, eigentlich schon gut. Weil es soll ja wahrscheinlich kein, also du machst das nicht im Kühlschrank, ZitrusRüchtlinge haben nichts im Kühlschrank verloren, die Zuhörer. Wir sind in der Koch-Ecke kurz abgedriftet. Wir rennen aber gleich wieder zurück ins Wohnzimmer, wo wir uns, wenn die Schuhe ausziehen können. Aber hier, aber in der, also Citrus-Rüchtlinge gehören nicht im Kühlschrank, also ist die Frage immer, oft hat man so eine Obstschale. Ne, was ich gerne hätte, wäre. Aber zu bleiben ist gut, weil dir kein Licht reinkale. Was ich gerne hätte, wäre so ein großer Glaskolben in der Küche, gefüllt mit Zitronen, wo unten so eine Schleuse, eine Schotte ist. Du machst die Schotten wieder auf? Kannst du ohne Schatten aufmachen, die Schotten aufzumachen? So dass, wenn man Zitronen braucht, macht man die Schotten auf und dann kullern die Zitronen raus, bis man genug hat, schottendicht und dann hat man die Zitronen. So will ich eigentlich Zitronen gelagert haben bei mir. Ich dachte gerade... Im M&M-Store, erinnerst du dich? New York M&M-Store? Diese grossen Glaskolben und man konnte dann diesen Hebel drücken und dann sind die rausgerieselt, bis man den Hebel wieder losgelassen hat.
Ja, aber ich glaube, um diese Rieselaktion zu bekommen, glaube ich, brauchst du kleinere Gegenstände. Ich glaube, Zitronen rieseln nicht.
Gut, andere Idee. Du hast einen grossen Glaskasten mit Zitronen und an dem Glaskasten hängt an einer Schnur eine Schaufel und daneben sind so Plastiktüten.
Du nimmst dir eine Plastiktüte und schaufelst dann mit der Schaufel die Zitronen in deine Plastiktüte. Du kennst das an der Kirmes, wo man dann für ein Date immer welchen Teddybär möchte und dann nimmt man diesen Greifel dran. Ja, den Greifer. Und das bei dir, nur mit Zitronen voll und du musst immer einen Fünfer rein schmeißen, um einmal eine Zitrone holen zu können.
Und dann entscheidest du daran.
Da es ja mein Automat ist in meiner Küche, habe ich auch den Schlüssel, um die Fünfer wieder rauszuholen.
Aber ich habe trotzdem immer ein Paar im Geldbeutel.
Und ich glaube, unterbewusst macht es trotzdem was mit dir.
Ja, total.
Weil du denkst, ich kann nicht wieder fünf Euro dafür ausgeben.
Und dann erst fällt dir ein, ah, ich kann nicht mehr einen Schlüssel dafür.
Ja.
Aber der Schlüssel ist auch in einem Automaten, in einem Schlüsselautomaten. Aber da ich auch den Schlüssel für den habe, kann ich mir rausgehen. Aber dann ist es jetzt vielleicht der perfekte Zeitpunkt, weil wir jetzt gerade über obskure Transportsysteme geredet haben, Thema Röhrenpost.
Sagt dir das was? Ja. Ich kenne das nur in einem Saturn in Hamburg. Ach so, nee, ich kenne es nicht mehr, ich habe es noch nie gesehen. Ich habe es einmal in der echten Welt gesehen, Röhrenpost, und zwar, ich weiß nicht, ob Saturn in der Mediamarkt ist, am Hamburger Hauptbahnhof, wo ich mir einen PC gekauft habe. Und da gab es dieses Röhrenpost-System, wo der wirklich dann gesagt hat, PC abholen, ja, unterschreiben Sie, unterschreiben. Dann tut er den Zettel in so eine Sonde rein und dann in die Röhre flunk, nimmt es seinen Weg. Wohin weiß niemand, aber es ist tatsächlich passiert, Röhrenpost. Um Gegenstände durchzuballern oder um Briefe? In dem Moment war es ein Zettel, aber es könnte natürlich auch ein kleines Neugeborenes sein. Was für Zettel müssen denn im Saturn in Hamburg und in keinem anderen Saturn? Ja, ich weiß es wirklich. Was für Zettel müssen in diesem Saturn transportiert werden? Ich habe keine Ahnung. Vielleicht ist es auch noch so ein Relikt aus alter Zeit oder sowas, dass es einfach nie geändert wurde. Wieso Paternoster? Paternoster oder zum Beispiel, da habe ich mich mal intensiv mit beschäftigt, es gibt ja so S-Bahn-Sicherheit, also nicht die Kontrolleure, sondern S-Bahn-Sicherheit und die gibt es auch in München und da gibt es noch eine U-Bahn-Sicherheit. Das ist eine komplett andere Truppe. Die U-Bahn-Sicherheit und die S-Bahn-Sicherheit. Und die U-Bahn-Sicherheit trägt Revolver. Ich stelle mir gerade vor, du hast ein Date und so. Und wir springen rein ins Gespräch und du sitzt vor ihr. Du bist aufgestanden vom Tisch, um sie anschaulicher erklären zu können. Nein, du verstehst nicht, es gibt die U-Bahn-Sicherheit und die S-Bahn-Sicherheit. Und sie sagt dir, auf deinen Bildern sahst du ja anders aus. Auf deinen Bildern war keine Flipchart, das hat mir besser gefallen. In einer Tenderbiografie stand U-Bahn-S-Bahn-Fan, von daher, there were some red flags along the way.
Aber du sagst anders aus.
Aber die Münchner U-Bahn-Sicherheit trägt Revolver.
Oh mein Gott, Revolver?
Wieso, hä?
Wieso haben die nicht schön so eine P99 wenig?
Ja, das ist eine verdammt gute Frage.
Weil sie nur sechs Mal schießen können.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie es immer noch machen, aber damals zur Zeit... Mit nur einem Schuss. Genau so eine Jack-Sparrow-Pistole. Ja, mit einem Schuss. Aber so silbar, gegen die Vampire. Ja, früher waren das die Vampirjäger. Und ich weiß nicht, ob es mittlerweile immer noch so ist, aber damals, als ich studiert habe, war es definitiv so, da standen dann Leute und vor allem, du sitzt ja in der U-Bahn, das heißt, diese U-Bahn-Sicherheit steht neben dir und auf deiner Augenhöhe ist da halt ein Revolver, halt wirklich so ein Oldschool-Western-Colt. Ja. Und die haben ja auch Sporen angehabt, das wäre einfach. Weil, aber wie cool, viel zu übertrieben. Unglaublich merkwürdig. Weil irgend so ein Waffenfan da drin saß, der kurz vor ein Jahr diesen Laden übernommen hat und gesagt hat, weißt du was, Revolver und alle so.
Irgendwann habe ich das mal recherchiert und habe angerufen bei der MVG Münchner Verkehrs-Cowboys und habe angerufen und habe recherchiert und bin bis zu einem Pressesprecher vorgedrungen, der irgendwo in einem Saloon saß und irgendwie so eine Münze hochgeschnippt hat und sich so... Was für Ihre Frage! Du stellst ganz schön viele Fragen. In dieser Stadt ist nur Platz für einen Fragesteller. Ich hoffe, du kannst mit der Antwort leben. Und dann habe ich den gefragt. Und du so, nee, danke, ich weiss schon.
Ich kann dir sechs Antworten geben.
Sieht der Nummer Räuber.
Ich kann dir sechs bis acht Antworten geben, je nach Modellnummer.
Okay.
Und dann habe ich mit ihm gesprochen und er meinte, ja, ja, die Frage kriegen wir ständig.
Das war die Antwort. Das war die gesunde Antwort. Die Frage, aber dass sie auch nicht mal irgendwie planen, okay, die Antwort kriegen sie ständig. Die Frage kriegen wir ständig und ich kann mich nicht mehr ganz genau die Antwort, aber nein, die Antwort war sowas wie, das ist irgendwann mal aus, das hat historische Gründe und es ist tatsächlich mal aus irgendeiner Polizeieinheit entstanden, die dann einfach nie geändert wurde. Also so ein klassisches, wie sich die meisten obskuren Sachen erklären, hat irgendeinen historischen Grund und es wurde halt einfach nie geändert. So niemand kam je auf die Idee, das zu ändern, weil es auch egal ist. Und dann meinte er, und genau das hast du auch schon angesprochen, und er meinte, und um ihre Frage vorwegzunehmen, nein, es musste noch nie ein Revolver abgefeuert werden. Schön. Also der Pressesprecher lebt ein Leben, in dem er zwei Fragen beantwortet, von denen er eine schon vorwegnehmen kann. Das ist sein Leben. Sind Pressesprecher die menschliche Formen von FAQs? Im Grunde schon. Und ist sein FAQ nicht basically zwei Fragen? Erstens warum und zweitens wie oft? Ja, genau. Und es ist aber auch viel Augenrollen dabei, auch diesen, die Frage kriege ich ständig als Pressesprecher. Oh Gott, nicht die Frage schon wieder. Boring, die Ermittlungen laufen noch. Entschuldigung, der schlechteste Pressesprecher. Das ist ja was für unseren Mittelalter-Film.
Der schlechteste Pressesprecher der Welt.
Oder der Pressesprecher vom König oder sowas.
Der dann auch so interviewt wird.
Aber von so einem, naja.
Nee,
ist kein Grund, den direkt so aufzugeben.
Müssen ja auch nicht alle Ideen in unseren Mittelalter-Filmen reinnehmen.
Nee, müssen auch nicht alle da rein.
Aber das ist auf jeden Fall auch so eine Sache.
Aber wie gesagt, ganz was anderes als die S-Bahn-Sicherheit, die Schwerter trägt. Auch das hat historische Gründe. Also jeder trägt ein Schwert. Und nein, es musste noch nie das Schwert gestochen werden. Aber wie geil, wenn du sagst, und nein, um ihre Frage vorwegzunehmen und dann was ganz anderes fragen. Eigentlich müsste man das viel häufiger machen, um deine Frage vorwegzunehmen, gelb. Die Frauen verdienen bei uns genauso viel wie die Männer. Und man denkt so, warum sollte man das sagen? Versucht man generell, mehr vorwegzunehmen, Einfach den Leuten direkt den Wind aus den Segeln nehmen.
Einfach sofort.
Dinge vorwegnehmen ist eine richtig gute Strategie.
So eine gute Strategie.
Ja, ich war beim Friseur.
Ja, ich habe ein bisschen zugenommen.
Nein, ich sammle keine Katanas mehr.
So, haben wir jetzt alles?
Okay, gut.
Sorry.
Okay.
Sorry, sorry. Aber ich finde auch, nur weil Dinge immer schon so gemacht werden, heißt es nicht, dass man sie nicht ändern sollen dürfte. Gut, weiter. Weil zum Beispiel gibt es ja auch viele, warum gibt es noch Nachkommastellen im Geld, frage ich mich. Warum kann man nicht einfach mal sagen, und ich glaube, alle wären cool damit, jetzt mal einmal kurz zu sagen, wir runden den Euro auf oder ab. War nicht so catchy. Aber wir killen die Nachkommastellen. Die kleinste Einheit ist ein Euro. Wie heißt das? Bruchpreis? Preisbruch? Es gibt keine Cents mehr. Es gibt keine Cents mehr. Keine Pennies, keine Pfennige, keine Mini-Franken, wie es in der Schweiz heißt. Dann hast du auch keine Eurolinge. Eurolinge ist nochmal, 100 Eurolinge sind 1 Cent, nervt eh. Die braucht man so gut wie nie. Die braucht man so gut wie nie. Die braucht man wirklich kaum. Ja, stimmt schon, aber ist natürlich ein großes Problem für Automaten. Weil ein KitKat kostet 1,20 Euro. Wie soll das gehen, wenn du kein Kleingeld zu handelst? Dann nicht mehr. Wie gesagt, wir runden alles auf und ab. Ja, aber dann würde man es ja, die KitKat-Schweine würden das ja wahrscheinlich nicht böse gemeint. Ich mag KitKat. Hey, wir geben uns mega viel Mühe. Wir arbeiten alle mega hart, dass dein KitKat so schmeckt, wie schmeckt. Ja, nein, aber... Sorry, aber es ist halt einfach so, ein Twix kostet einen Euro und ein KitKat kostet 1,20 Euro. Ja, aber wir mögen halt den Podcast so und wir müssen halt... Ja, nee, okay. Dann muss man sowas hören. Okay. Wir geben uns mega Mühe so und es ist halt einfach auch viel Arbeit, diese ganzen Aurang-Utans umzubringen, damit wir das scheiß Palmenöl bekommen. Ja, ich weiß. Ja, ich weiß, dass es eine Menge Arbeit ist. Nee, nur dass ein bisschen Dankbarkeit da mal reinfiehen. Ja, ich bin ja dankbar. Es tut mir auch leid, dass ich was gesagt habe, aber es ist nur mal auffällig, dass es 1,20 kostet, wohingegen die Malteser kosten 70 Cent.
Malteser.
Okay, dann hol den Malteser. Wenn der Malteser so gut schmeckt und so gut bezahlbar ist, dann ist doch ein Malteser.
Das habe ich doch gar nicht gesagt. Ich hole mir doch gerne einen KitKat.
Doch, du kannst doch gut streiten.
Die würden es ja auf zwei Euro raufsetzen, die KitKat-Schweine, so wie ich die kenne, oder? So. Das war's. Nee, ja, vielleicht ja, aber viele Dinge würden sich auch herunter... Nein, das darf nicht sein, zumindest nicht am Anfang. Weil meine Regel ist ja, wir runden alles auf und auf. Ja, und du stehst dann neben jedem Automaten Deutschlands, Stefan Teze steht neben dem Tomaten und sagt, nein, nein, nein, das darf nicht sein. Das willst du mir jetzt gerade weismachen, oder was? Wieso, weil ich immer reimend spreche. Nein, alles, sag mal, alles ab 51 wird aufgerundet, der Rest wird abgerundet. Ja, was ist mit Maltesern, die kosten 70 Cent. Ein Euro. Ja, aber dann zahl ich doch mehr für Malteser. Ja, aber du zahlst ja auch weniger für andere Sachen. Ich glaube, im Schnitt kommt das aufs Gleiche raus, Florentin. Wirklich jetzt mal. Weil so viele Dinge auf der Welt 54,99 Euro kosten, weil du auf die Vorkommastelle achtest. Und deswegen, die werden ja alle... Ach nee, die werden ja auch aufgerundet. Naja, das wird sich ja ausgleichen, glaube ich. Das wird sich ja ausgleichen. Bin ich schon sehr zuversichtlich. Ich gehe immer gern zu diesen Automaten. Aber ich schäme mich immer dafür, wenn da jemand davor steht beim Bahnhof, steht direkt vorm Automaten, macht das erstmal nicht, steht davor und dann läuft man so hin und dann versucht man erst so durch Körpersprache. Ja, weil du ein Recht hast, da zu stehen, mehr als er. Ach nein, auf gar keinen Fall. Und dann versuche ich es erst durch Körpersprache, daran vorbeizulaufen, mal so zu gucken, aha, was gibt es denn Leckeres? Und wenn die Person dann auch nicht weggeht, weil ich bin nicht selbstlos genug zu sagen, Entschuldigung, kann ich kurz, ich würde gern einfach mir ein bisschen süssen Zuckerspaß
gönnen, ja, ich bin acht Jahre
alt, ja, um die Frage vorwegzunehmen,
ja, ich habe schon die
1,20 Euro schon abgezählt
in meiner linken Hand,
schon ein bisschen schwitzig das Geld geworden,
weil ich die sehr presse, weil ich Lust habe,
jetzt schön meinen Riegel zu holen. Und wenn ihr meinen Finger jetzt angucken
würdet, hättest du einen 20 Cent Abdruck drauf.
Schön Michelangelo, schön David drauf, habe ich schön direkt drauf.
Aber das ist immer unangenehm.
Also machst du es nicht, schiebst du nicht beiseite.
Nee, mache ich nicht. Wirklich immer mit Körpersprache.
Und das ist ein Rüttelzug von der Seite ganz so lange Automaten in der Hoffnung, dass die Seitentür aufgeht.
Hat doch jeder schon mal gemacht, einfach mal, man hat nicht genug Geld dabei. Aber ich weiß nicht, ich mag Menschen. Ganz im Ernst, ich mag Menschen. Und sag doch warum. Weil alle ... Nimm das zurück, Schadam, nimm das zurück. Alle hassen gerade, ja, komm mal, du bist einer von denen auf dem Menschenhasser Zug. Vor allem, ich fühle mich nicht angesprochen. Wenn du sagst Menschen, denke ich, ja, Menschen sind doof. Aber ich fühle mich nicht angesprochen. Aber weißt du, warum ich die mag? Weil Menschen sind neugierig. Und wenn nämlich so ein Automaten mal aufgemacht wird, die Blicke.
Alle gucken da rein. Und ich denke mal, wie cool ist das denn? Tiere, wenn eine Katze bei dir rumläuft.
So, und dann hast du den Automaten und machst den Automaten auf. Egal.
Ist dir völlig egal. Die Kinder leben ihr Leben. Wenn eine Katze auf dem Bahnsteig wäre, wäre das scheißegal. Taube, oh cool, reinig hinterher, mega, geil, cooler Tag. So, Menschen gucken rein, Menschen bleiben stehen, beenden ihre Anrufe, sagen, sorry, ich rufe wieder nochmal an, um in den fucking offenen Automaten zu gucken. Ich war mal mit Kindern in München unterwegs, als ich so eine Ferienbetreuung gemacht habe für Kinder. Und da mussten wir auch irgendwo hinfahren mit der S-Bahn. Furchtbarste, was es gibt, weil jedes Kind kann jederzeit weg sein und du musst konstant alles durchzählen. Ja, da soll es kaputtgesäbelt werden von so. Ja, oder einfach irgendwie so, kann ich mal das Kabel anfassen? Tot. Und da war auch einer von diesen Leuten, die den Snackautomat befüllt haben. Und eines der Kinder ist hingegangen zu dem und
hat gesagt, kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Und er meinte so, ja. Und dann hat er denen
so die Packung gegeben und das Kind hat dann in den Automaten
gestiegen. Dieses Kind war die nächsten drei
Tage das glücklichste
Kind der Welt. Wirklich.
Es braucht nicht viel, aber das Kind
hat sich, und dann dachte ich eigentlich auch so, das Kind
weiss, was es glücklich macht,
jetzt irgendwie da die Süßigkeiten einzusortieren und es geht da hin und sagt, darf ich das machen? Und er sagt ja. Und das Kind ist danach glücklich. Dieses Kind hat mehr verstanden, als ich jemals werde. Was macht das Kind heute? Das Kind holt sich das, was es glücklich macht und ist danach glücklich. Und es ist perfekt. Das war der perfekte Tag einfach. Weißt du, wie das Kind heisst? Nein, Mike, glaube ich. Was macht Mike heute? Ich weiß es nicht, müsste man nochmal anrufen. Heissen Kinder, aber A-I, A-I-K. Ich habe nie ein Kind gesehen, was Mike heisst. Mike. Nee, Mike gibt es frühestens ab 14. Ja? Es gibt keine Kinder-Mikes, oh Scheiss. Es gibt keine Kinder-Mikes. Doch, der hieß Mike, Mike Drop hieß der. MacDrop. Es gibt aber auch keine, es gibt keine Kinder-Mikes. Oh, Scheiss. Ich kenne kein, es gibt keine Kinder-Mikes. Doch, der hieß Mike. Mike Drop hieß der. Mike Drop. Es gibt aber auch keine, wie es keine Tauben, Babytauben gibt. Aha. Gibt's nicht. Und so ist es mit Mikes auch. Es gibt die nicht als Baby. Die werden ab 14 gebrochen. Ich glaube, er hieß Mike, aber vielleicht hieß er auch anders. Aber ich glaube schon. Weißt du, was Mike heute macht? Ich müsste mal anrufen, ich müsste mal anrufen. Ich habe tatsächlich noch von ein paar Kindern habe ich die Handynummer. Weil die damals schon Handys hatten oder weil die später, als sie zuerst mal Handy hatten, das... Nee, nee, die hatten Handys und dann war es immer so, die Eltern haben darauf bestanden, dass man die Handynummer der Kinder dann irgendwie einspeichert, dass falls sie verloren geht, ein Mann mit denen in Kontakt treten kann und so. Und dann ist es immer so, schreiben Sie jetzt die Nummer Ihrer Tochter auf. Ich so, wirklich, ist das okay Nummer Ihrer Tochter? Ja, schreiben Sie auf. Und dann hast du halt die Nummer von so einem zehnjährigen Mädchen in deinem Handy. Und du auch denkst, das kann ganz böse enden. Aber immer wenn ich meine Kontakte durchscroll, komme ich über die und denke mir, könnt mich mal wieder melden. Hatten die moderne Handys? Ja, so ein Snoopy-Handy einfach. Hallo, hallo? Dosentelefone. Aber auch so einseitige Handys, wo die nur empfangen können, aber nicht sprechen. So was in der Richtung. So ein Fisher-Price-Handy. Gesundheit. Dankeschön. Stefan. Niesen macht es auch glücklich.
Ich habe danach schon das Gefühl,
da wird so eine Art Botenstoff ausgeschickt,
der mich ein bisschen glücklich macht.
Muss man so ausladen, niesen eigentlich,
oder macht man es, weil es Spaß macht?
Also wirklich so, ich denke mir, manchmal bei Niesen, den hole ich mir,
den mache ich groß.
Ja, wie so ein Homerun,
also man nimmt den Ball auf sich zufliegen
und denkt, den verwandle ich.
Ja, es gibt manche Fallrückzieher, Nieser, wo man einfach sagt, ist nicht nötig, aber mache ich es einfach. Habe ich jetzt einfach Bock drauf. Ja, Niesen und Schein. Ja, die Aerosole fliegen durch den Raum, wenn man denkt, oh yes. Aber es ist, da weiß man bei vielen Dingen nicht, ob es sein muss, weil du kannst ja zum Beispiel auch gähnen, gibt es ja auch so in der Etikette, dass man gähnt, ohne den Mund aufzumachen. Du kannst ja wirklich immer hübscheln. Aber das kriegst du ja hin, aber trotzdem zelebrierst du manchmal. Und dann nochmal, wo das sein muss. Wenn man sich hinsetzt, wenn man dieses endlich sitzen mässige Geräusch macht, muss man ja nicht. Nee, muss man nicht. Denkt man sich auch, den hole ich mir jetzt. Es sind, glaube ich, so diese Frustschreie des kleinen Mannes. So dieses, was man in den Filmen kennt, dieses Kissen schreien oder mal vor die Tür gehen, dieses Shawshank Redemption. Er kommt raus, weint die Arme aus im Gewitter und schreit, das ist doch ein Nieser zu verwandeln. Im Grunde schon. Der kurze Freifahrtschein, dieser eine umsonst. Ja, ich glaube, man könnte die Hälfte der Energie sich sparen, wenn man Dinge nur so macht, wie man sie machen muss, wirklich aufs Mindeste reduziert. Aber es sind oft auch Gesprächsanfänger tatsächlich. Ich glaube, das ist was, was wir nicht so gut kennen, weil wir nicht das Bedürfnis haben, mit Fremden zu sprechen und so.
Aber das sehe ich manchmal auch bei Kassierern, dass sie dann so, oh, langer Tag heute.
Wiedersehen.
Spille.
Nichts.
Aber ich denke so, ja, wahrscheinlich ist es ja, ja, ja. So und so ist so ein auch so, das ist dann so, man guckt
jemanden in die Augen und macht so ein
ja, langer Tag heute.
Und so, da können Gespräche entstehen.
Das stimmt, es ist auch merkwürdiger, dann nach
Stille, das ist auch fast nie
existent. Nach so einem krassen Nieser
danach, dass niemand was sagt, das wäre eher
unüblich. Es wäre eher so, oh, hast du was
weggeholt? Ja, gestern war ich in Fattattasienland zwei Stunden im Regen gestehen.
Ich frage mich, an welchem Punkt es zu viel ist, wo die Leute dann auch, also wo man es dann ironisch spricht, also wenn man den Nieser zu gross macht, also wirklich Komiker. Und alle so Gesundheit, gerade ironisch geniesst. Was sollte das bedeuten? Die Arme hochwerfen, hat nicht geholfen. Die Arme wie so diese Aufblasfiguren vor so Gebrauchtwagenbläden. Links und rechts. Aber ich habe einen Kumpel, der immer wieder eine Lanze dafür bricht für den Wetter-Talk.
Weil der Wetter-Talk ist zu Unrecht seiner Meinung nach in den Verruf geraten.
Man sagt, jetzt reden wir schon wieder über das Wetter.
Und wenn man nichts hat, dann reden wir über das Wetter.
Und mittlerweile ist es auch so etwas wie Serien, ist das Neue, der Wetter-Talk.
Hast du das schon gesehen? Ich gucke gerade.
Aber eigentlich ist doch Wetter perfekt. Weil es ist ja auch spannend für jeden. Ich bin ein, das ich in der Zeit, die ich in der Zeit, die ich in der Zeit, die ich in der Zeit, die ich in der Zeit, die ich weiß, was los ist. So magical, the elements machen ihre Magie. Und irgendwie ist es natürlich auch spannend, darüber zu reden, immer mal wieder. Und dann gab es auch eine Vorhersage, es war auch wie eine Wette. Also es ist auch dieser spielerische Aspekt mit drin. Hm, hat gesagt, es soll das und das tun. Gestern haben die aber gemeint, aber die haben auch nie recht. Da gibt es dieses Mysterium über die Vorhersage. Gemeinsames Autorität anzweifeln. Aber ich habe ja eine App, ich habe diese norwegische Wetter-App, die ist richtig gut. Jeder hat dann diese norwegische Wetter-App, die genauso immer falsch ist. Regenradar, ich habe einen Regenradar. Jeder hat dann dieses eine, dieses Technik-Gimmick. Wenn du das wirklich mal den Quellcode
von einer Wetter-App anschaust, ist irgendwo
ein Zufallsmechanismus drin.
Ich glaube wirklich, das ist mein Experiment.
Stefan, jetzt schreib mal mit.
Wetter-App, gehypte App,
gehypte App, Doppelpunkt,
Wetter-App, gehypte App, gehypte App, Doppelpunkt, Wetter-App, die rein... Und dann zwischendurch immer, wo man merkt, wenn das Geräusch kommt, hat man sich verschrieben. Dann brauchst du gar nicht weiterreden, weil ich ja noch beim Löschen bin. Ja, vor allem, du musst einfach wahnsinnig viel löschen. Was löscht du alles? Und noch schlimmer ist... Das Unkontrollierte. Und es gibt auch nicht viele Stufen. Es gibt nur, es wird langsam und dann geht es weg. Gehalbte App, Doppelpunkt, Wetter-App, die allein auf Zufallsmechanismen beruht.
Nonsens-Vorhersagen, wild ausgewürfelte Temperaturen und dann schauen, Doppelpunkt, wie viele Leute trotzdem darauf zugreifen und die gut finden. So, perfekt. Ich glaube, das würde funktionieren. Ich glaube auch. Ich glaube, das würde total gut funktionieren. Hat bestimmt schon mal jemand gemacht. Irgendwas zufällig gemacht und dann den Leuten sagen, es ist eine tolle Vorhersage. Weiß man nicht. Ja, wahrscheinlich schon. Ehrlich gesagt, kann ich mir das gut vorstellen. Ja. Wobei bei Wetter glaube ich, ist es ganz, ganz grosser Unsinn, weil das würde sofort auffallen. Wenn man diese Wochenansicht hat und das muss man dann in den Zufallsmechanismus mit einprogrammieren, dass du halt, dass sich nur um bis zu fünf Grad verändert oder so. Da schreib mal was, da kannst du schon was schreiben. Ja gut, aber dann wird es nicht mehr so catchy, deine Headline. Du liebst auch catchy Headlines. Ja, ja, klar, ich liebe gute. Niemand vergisst Rehwatte keine Zitrusfrüchte mehr. Das war die Gute. Das war die letzte Gute. Ich habe eine Vorhersage für euch. Und zwar, ihr habt eine richtig schöne Woche, ihr Lieben. Und in einer Woche sehen wir uns wieder, dann geht es wieder weiter. Bis dahin wünschen wir euch eine fantastische Zeit. Wünschen wir euch eine fantastische Zeit. Habt eine gute Zeit. Geht mal raus, geht mal rein. Macht die Schotten auf.
Macht die Schotten auf, wir sehen uns nächste Woche.
Bis dahin, wir heben ab, macht's gut, ciao. Ciao, ciao.
It's a worst fucking Burr-Production.